eighty percent of women on hinge have  their height limits set to six foot or  above for men that's less than ten or  fifteen percent of men in the United  States or above six foot and height has  zero predictive ability when it comes to  looking at long-term relationship  happiness imagine you saying to me I  only date girls who are a size four and  a half shoe I'd be like why this is  anecdotal but I feel as though girls  hold more of an animus towards these  dating apps they say look if I'm gonna  get on hinge I'm gonna get the best of  the best and if it doesn't work no  problems for me I don't give a [ __ ] if I  get one match if I get 10 matches I'm on  this thing to not get [ __ ] over if I'm  gonna get someone they better be tall  they better be good looking they better  be this this and this